tell me about the neighborhood okay so I
have a neighbor a couple couple houses
down we walk past it with my friend
Shane D and it has I'd say maybe three
thousand lemons fully ripe ready for
ready to be picked so my friend Shane
he's like oh let's knock on his door and
ask him for some lemons which i think is
a reasonable thing to do do it as a
reasonable thing very neighborly we have
a fig tree that grows into an alley and
and homeless people harvest our figs
that grow into the alley okay and they
like take all the figs and so when you
go to take figs you look oh we've got
more on the other side and the other
side is empty
yeah okay keep going
circle thinking circle thinking circle
thinking guys she politely knocks on his
door and says excuse me sir can I have
some of your lemons and he says first
actually he waits twenty seconds and
he's not sure if he even wants to give
us one lemon and then he says yeah you
can have two this was months ago right
within everything now is dead and rotten
he has not picked a single [ __ ] lemon
from his own tree and he didn't want to
give us any more than two that's it that
that is [ __ ] up when you hear on paper
now you ready what so no way to argue
that but this is there's no it are you I
can but what I can do is I can empathize
whatever this is and I wonder if people
will hear this that way so we have we
have a big party one night and and for
whatever reason no one drank beer and so
we had a whole igloo freezer cooler full
of beer and where it was placed it was
it had a towel over it no one saw it and
so it's at there forever so then all of
a sudden one day I go oh [ __ ] this I
open it and all the water smells like
[ __ ] and all the beers labels are faded
and so I take out all the beers and then
I go I'm gonna throw him why I'm no
one's drinking these [ __ ] beers I'll
put him in the alley put him in the
alley and I no sooner leave my house to
go to Starbucks and I start walking by
the alley and I see a homeless guy
grabbing my beers and my immediate
instinct was hey they'll take my [ __ ]
beers so I didn't want them I didn't
want them and I put him in the alley for
someone to take and as he was taking
I was like I am stink was don't take my
beers I didn't want to see it yes like I
didn't want to see them I would be I our
neighbor has lemon tree and I always I
always say to oh hey George mind if I
grab a lemon
by the way I've literally described my
where I live to a tea if you looking for
a lemon tree of Starbucks in an alley
here and a half-full fig tree and a big
tree you're like I think I always asked
him if I can have his lemons I would
never take lemon without him asking
without asking him but he says take all
the lemons because it lemon trees have
tons of [ __ ] lemons well he always
says take the lemons that's where I grab
two for you guys what thank you tell
them what I do at a restaurant if I pay
so if he pays I'm picking out some
people let's say you ordered a $65 steak
tastes delicious you only eat half you
want to take some home to your kids and
I'm paying for it if he's paying for it
you're not allowed to take anything
wrapped up and then Bobby just goes yeah
one box no I leave I don't even take it
in fact I've done this before I leave it
on the table I no one can take it I've
taken the box I've secretly packed it in
a box and he's done this to a sandwich
of mine looked at it smashed my sandwich
so it's now all over the place in and
out of it you pay for the meal you can
take it home do whatever you want with
that is so brilliant thank you so much I
loved I pay for a lot of meals
yeah and there is a point like where
it's like I was with some friends the
other day and they were like we were
getting we were leaving and they were
sitting at a different table than we
were like we had to do you have two
tables and so we had two different bills
and I got up I was one of the bathroom
and they looked at me in there like hey
do you wanna like grab this and I was
like oh yeah y'all grab it and I was
like then I was like looking at all the
food on the table and I was like I
didn't even I didn't even share the
conversation
enjoy yeah like I would do that harpy
let me ask you a question if you're
eating this is a problem of mine if last
night okay